in
july
thank you we all know the concept of
space time however
space time is practically unknown
geologists archaeologists
frequently work with very similar concepts
the volcano the volcanoes of western
mexico vicente can help us to
develop this theory if we are able
to  stay still observe the
territory imagine the past
rebuild what we believe the
future can be and all this
through the block of jalisco blocks of
jalisco is a geological and
geographical region with a diamond shape
precisely explains much of
the seismic activity  and the volcano of
western Mexico or the ships of the
millennia with a series of very
recognizable volcanoes. The communities that
interest me the most to work on this
aspect are two mattresses in an
original town and
earth scientists in more specifically the
contemporary geophysicists
before before there was the
Mesoamerican concept of the florida mountain
before reaching the Spanish is this
place is where tlaloc resided it could
also be the residence of Dátolo costa
local and in addition to keeping
fresh water onions we can try to update
these ideas and perhaps find him
appeared in the territory
religious rituals of the huichols the call
that carl and that also has a
diamond shape where they practice a large part
of their
ancestral regions according to téllez the
ceremonial songs that guide the spiritual journey
to the inland including mentions of
intimate feelings that have long since disappeared
or  are inaccessible today some of
these sites have been destroyed
looted is part of the desolate
mining farms fields
although the two sacred people the
Huichols or insurers of
spiritual authority can dream of
that site to find them
precisely one of them is considered
a series of testimonies such as an ancient
volcano at the top of it could be
found the spirits of the
deceased of the ancient gods and of
the unborn children who lived
in the 19th century santoscoy an academic
that I will find
the Aztec hell precisely in
what it would be  the jalisco block reading
about prehispanic and colonial cults
it would be generated from tepic to hell it would go
from tepic to colima
literally following the border of what we
know today are the scientific lines and limits
of the jalisco block the
weapon difficulties correspond
to those  sites is not this leads us to
a series of questions
we have mythological sites with
us and we use them on earth
it is the earth that explains to us
how it can always be and we have to
be carrying the passions that
although ancient in moors it was  In the
19th century, the activity of Seboruco and the
Colima volcano led to a new interest
in biological physicists. For example,
this image of the Colima volcano is very
far away with photographs of it as
part of its knowledge.
Geophysicists
also have a  Emotional and
spiritual connection with the territory Acebo tenor,
for example, sir, that his soul
took possession of a cloud in the
Colima volcano and then it comes volcanic in the
Caribbean to reach Poland, his place, his
home. Fernando's last article is
all about the chair  Primavera, which is
found under a name Joel Bosqued, is
of the same name, which may be the only
real one for a wide area of ​​the West and
Mexico,
and yet, before highlighting these
risks in the article at the beginning, new
accounts of the studies on the
six hundred pre-Columbian and  The
geological formations such as the attraction
that oscillates in the tequila volcano
studied this movement supposed the
reflection of the limits of Mesoamerica
the engineer's donation are only the
most straight things form the nucleus of the
paleontology museum of guadalajara his son he
pays tribute of dreams  and thinking about
the moment in which a radical change
would take humanity to the region was
utopian in the long now
space-time is the disk cited
main traveled through time
we our communities but the
way in which it is not being explored  we can
build the region is space time
or how they are being built and they
have saved some of the time in
a few tens of thousands of years those of
jalisco can become an island
we head north and maybe at that
time we can meet again
us, our descendants, and
talk about everything that has
allowed us to understand what Jalisco is about
time,
and finally, I would like to thank
my colleagues for helping me
organize these ideas, the images, and give
meaning to the landscapes from time to the
past.  present
the future including paradise thanks
thanks to being taken for the twin
awards and action water table kinect
landscape
I think that the Colima volcano but
also the Tequila volcano and the
surrounding visuals gives a lot of play for the
whole issue of
obsidian deposits the attempts  that there is to
maintain the mine the
archaeological studies and to find deposits to
preserve them the industrial development of
tequila is a very rich region very
interesting and that still has a lot of
future
thanks to doing